[Music]
really
fly
hey
hey
did you just do that you took that
batman through the wall
how'd you do that
well little girl
you didn't see anything you see that
hole was already there that's an optical
illusion
no
what i saw was you serve that
try this
come on
wait up wait up
what do you do with all this junk
keeps me busy
another long night of crime and violence
some say it's only a matter of time
before the city implodes
i think we're finished here come on beat
it
i found him
samaritan
samaritan died 25 years ago
that's what they say
you think you live across from a
superhero
do you have a therapist kid
good
samaritan's dead
i pick up garbage for a living foul
meredith cleaned up the streets
you mind your business on my mind i
don't believe you
are you okay
i'm cool
how strong are you
kind of struggling that once was things
start to fall apart when you stop
carrying
i stopped carrying a long time ago
how come you hate who you are
for some people it's too late to change
the damage they've done
he's hiding something
i want him dead
really
[Music]
the things you bury tend to haunt you
why did you disappear
hey old man
try this
[Music]
you